nous sommes quelque part au milieu du
pacifique
une île minuscule et inhabitée sofa des
oiseaux quelques bernard l'hermite et
des tortues géantes un petit coin de
paradis où trois hommes se sont
retrouvés en détresse sauver seulement
grâce au sos qu'ils ont dessiné sur le
sable il était parti jeudi pour relier
deux atolls distant d'à peine 30 km mais
ils sont tombés en panne et on dérivait
plus de 200 kilomètres vers l'ouest
leur disparition est signalée des
militaires américains et australiens
sillonnent le secteur
un avion de reconnaissance des vies de
sa route pour éviter une averse et tombe
sur la plage avec ses trois immenses
lettres faite de morceaux de bois à côté
une cabane de fortune
les trois rescapés et leurs bateaux
l'aco vide a compliqué le sauvetage des
vivres ont d'abord été largué avec des
parachutes et puis les secours se sont
déployés sur l'eau avant d'accoster en
tout distanciation pour s'assurer que
les hommes étaient en bonne santé
c'est finalement un patrouilleur de la
marine de micronésie qui embarquera les
naufragés pour les ramener à bon port où
ils pourront raconter comment ils
doivent leur vie à un petit palindrome
ici mathieu prost radio-canada à
montréal